SPEAKER: One of the
essentials of citizenship
is a presence or the
creation and the preservation
of a large middle class.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
This idea goes all the way back
to Greece where citizenship
first developed, and they
had a word for it, the mesoi,
M-E-S-O-I. In their
way of thinking,
you had to have the majority
of citizens self-employed,
independent, outspoken,
and neither rich nor poor.
The middle class alone were
neither dependent on the state
nor did they emulate or
do they envy the rich.
And so these mesoi and the
idealized Greek city-state
were the citizens that showed
up in the assembly hall,
they were outside, and they had
an equal seat on stone benches.
That equality was reflected
in the military sense
by slots and the phalanx.
That is the armed
squares of Spearman
that fought the battles
of the city-state.
And finally, there was a third
dimension of the middle class
and that was the agrarian
grid outside the city-state.
Most land was parceled as
it was during the Homestead
Act in the United States
into 10 acre parcels.
The citizen also had
to be independent.
They were in control of the
laws, they made the laws,
and they were not
subject to coercion
from the poor or the rich.
There's another idea that comes
from the ancient world that's
important to remember that
something about being in charge
of your own destiny combines
the mental with the physical.
And by that, I mean in
the pre-industrial world
most people were farmers.
So they would get
up in the morning
and they would
prune vines or they
would have to plant olive
trees or in the spring,
they would cut
grain or thresh it,
but it was a
constant physical job
but yet they were
making decisions.
It was a mental task.
And to the Greeks,
this combination
of mental acuity and
physical strength
made the perfect balance.
Now, we all can't
be farmers today.
Only 1% of the
nation farms, but we
have all of these tasks today.
The independent
trucker, think about it.
He has to have endurance to
get on that highway for 16,
17 hours, but yet, he has to
make the decisions, which job
shall I take, how much
does diesel fuel cost,
and the same thing holds
true of the business person.
If you work for
a corporation you
make very important
decisions but
the independent
businessperson is
responsible for his own
destiny or her destiny,
and one mistake can
destroy their family.
They're not a cog in
a corporate wheel.
So what I'm suggesting
to you is maybe
we can't be all
small farmers or we
can't be all middle class,
small business people,
but we need this
group to be present,
because without
this present, you
do not have these
independent voices
and we don't combine the
physical and the mental and
of people who take
responsibility for themselves.
OK, so middle class
citizenship is
crucial in the history of
constitutional government.
Unfortunately in our
generation, it's eroding,
and we can see it erode
in a variety of contexts.
The first is for 10
years, average wages
of the middle
class did not rise.
50% of the country dies
with less than $10,000
in aggregate wealth.
Over half of Americans
die with credit card debt.
Their buying
options are limited,
their choices on how
they live are limited,
their chances at home
ownership decline simply
because they owe a lot of debt.
Nowhere is this more dramatic
than in student loans.
When the student
graduates, the average loan
is somewhere between
$30,000 and $40,000.
We have an entire generation of
students that are graduating--
often with therapeutic degrees--
and are not able to find
jobs that would allow them
to pay off this enormous debt.
If we came from Mars and
we looked at the situation,
we would just simply say
you have tens of thousands
of serfs or indentured servants.
If they're not beholden
to their credit cards,
they're beholden to
the federal government
and the universities.
[MUSIC PLAYING]